fuel is being pumped into a storage tank
the volume V of the fuel in the tank
depends on the depth D according to the
formula V of D is equal to four times
three d squared plus five to the third
power where D is measured in meters
suppose that the depth D of the fuel
depends on time measured in hours
according to the formula D of T is equal
to one over the square root of three
times the square root of t minus five
and that makes sense that if I'm filling
if I'm pumping something into a storage
tank the depth could the depth of of
what I'm filling of the fuel I guess is
what I'm feeling is going to depend on
time and then the volume could be
dependent on the depth use function
composition to write the volume of the
fuel in the tank as a function of time
simplify your answer as much as possible
so let me get my scratch pad out so I've
already written what they told us here
this is volume as a function of depth
and now this is depth as a function of
time so if we want volume as a function
of time what we really want to do is
figure out what is so we could take V of
D we could take V of D of T V of D of T
D of T now this will give me volume as a
function of time so everywhere where I
see a D I should replace it with this
description I should replace it with
this description of how does D vary with
respect to time so let's do that so V of
D of T is going to be equal to four
times three times d squared but instead
of writing d squared I'm going to write
all of this business squared so one over
square root of three times the square
root of t minus five all of that squared
plus five plus five to the third power I
really hope this simplifies in a
reasonable way so let's see let me
actually copy and paste this so I can
have a little bit more real estate
let me just paste it down here so I
could work it out all right so then we
get this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to let's see if we
square this right over here and I could
do it all in so this is going to be four
times three times this whole thing
squared so this whole thing squared 1
over square root of three squared is
going to be one third one third and then
square root of t minus five squared is
going to be t minus five and then of
course we have plus five plus five to
the third power
let's see three times 1/3 well that's
just going to be equal to one and so we
are left with this is equal to four
times t minus five t minus five plus
five this does simplify nicely plus five
so it's going to we're going to be left
with four times T to the third power
four times T to the third power so let's
input that into our and so V of T and
let me just make it clear this is what
this is now V this is giving our volume
as a function of time we can now say
that this is V of T V of T is four T
squared once again this is the volume as
a function of time you give me a time
I'll tell you what the volume is so for
T to the third for T to the third power
V of T so I say 4 T squared I don't know
sometimes I do strange things I said 4 T
to the third power 4 T to the third
power and it did format it correctly and
then there's a second part of this
question how many cubic meters of fuel
are in the tank after two hours round
your answer to the nearest tenth well
two hours this means T is equal to two
they say T is measured in hours so when
T is equal to two the volume is going to
be so two to the third power is 8 8
times 4 is 32 32 and let's check our
answer and we got it right